ok
can you guys hear me
we should be going live here in a second
what do we think about the new Fantastic
Four
yeah definitely to talk about that here
in a minute the new Fantastic Four we're
going to have a discussion about that
one here in a second YouTube like
definitely superhero static shock womp
womp there's no way Jaden Smith is
static shock what no way
alright no there's no way that Jaden
Smith a static shock that's crazy good
morning everyone a wild Rob appears yes
a wild Rob doesn't be oh my goodness so
um so keep in mind guys as always down
in the description you guys will find a
link to a YouTube channel the YouTube
channel is a growing youtube channel
it's actually comic world and as you
guys know at the beginning of comics a
coffee I always just grab a YouTube
channel from the self-promotion section
of the weekly pull form so if you guys
are trying to get your YouTube channel
grown and you guys want to have a
featured at some point here on comics
and coffee then that's the place to go
but but n even as you guys know is these
are channels that are starting out these
are channels that are growing these are
channels that are moving up in the world
and they're trying to you know get a
feel for themselves and so on and so
forth so a lot of these channels may be
very new they may be that the quality
may not be the greatest ever but
everybody starts somewhere so you know
give them a shot and take a look at them
let them know give them some feedback
something like that but but yes so so we
need to talk YouTube we need to have a
conversation all right we're going to
we're going to go to my office and we're
going to we're going to have a
conversation I can't help but notice
that over the last you know several
months or so since the announcement of
the Fantastic Four basically that people
have been freaking out about Michael B
Jordan and Johnny Storm being a black
dude
this is ridiculous all right look guys
when Fox announced that they were doing
a reboot of the Fantastic Four and I saw
the trailer wasn't though I was looking
at the trailers oh my god Johnny Storm
is black that was the last thing on my
mind all right this is a movie where we
have an 8-foot tall guy who's made of
rock all right we have a woman that can
make herself invisible and make force
fields using her mind we've got a guy
that can stretch himself all over the
place on the character in question can
set himself on fire and become as hot as
the Sun and they're able to do this
because they go to another dimension
called the negative zone and in the
process they gain their powers now this
idea stems from the same concept the
same world that gave us a teenage kid
who was bitten by a radioactive spider
and instead of dying from radioactive
sickness he developed spider related
powers all right is it really that crazy
to believe that maybe Johnny Storm could
be black in the Fantastic Four film I
mean it's it's a continuity error okay
who cares in the Marvel Cinematic
University on continuity errors all the
time in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the guardians of the galaxy came
together because Ron in the accuser had
the power gym and was probably going to
destroy you knows and are and take over
the universe or something stupid like
that and the comic books that came
together because a villain of the
Fantastic Four named Annihilus was
wiping out life in the universe using an
army of bugs and captain america the
winter soldier all right Bucky Barnes is
the winter soldier because you fell off
a train in the first captain america
film and was frozen in ice and then he
was discovered by the Russians in the
comics he got blown up by a plane I mean
yes there's continuity errors who cares
who cares if you're going to judge a
film if you're going to judge an actor
in a film judge the actor based on their
acting talent judge them on how well
they give us a character how
well can Michael B Jordan make Johnny
Storm believable don't judge a base on
his skin color that's preposterous it's
it's nonsense so anyway having said that
let us jump into this Q&A section
because I matter there's gonna be a lot
of questions about secret wars and
apparently Jaden Smith is Casa static
shock which I'm not a hundred percent
sure who static shock is but Jaden Smith
cast and anything except for like The
Karate Kid which was like named wrong it
should have been the kung fu kid but
nonetheless James Samantha anything
other than that is is going to be crap
so how will the Avengers you night after
Civil War see I don't know so you know
that was kind of the funny thing the
funny thing about civil war when it
happened in the comics was that once it
was all over everybody was like like
Tony Stark we hate you like everybody
hate it when he saw no one like Tony
Stark Tony Stark didn't even like Tony
Stark so I'm curious to see how all
that's going to play out I here's the
question somebody actually raised this
question pretty well in the chat too
what if it's a reversal of roles what if
Captain America is the one in support of
registration and what if Tony Stark is
not he's the one against registration
that would be a really cool concept for
the MCU I don't know if we'll actually
see a play out that way most likely will
see a play out with Captain America on
the side of freedom because Americans
heads would blow up if Captain America
was not on the side of freedom though
they would just be like what they would
lose their minds but um no no no I mean
it's it's the way that they basically
United after that is after Civil War and
I don't really think we've gone over
this but once civil war ended in Marvel
Comics we had like a 34 issue limited
series called the initiative and the
initiative was originally initially
supposed to be a miniseries like that
was supposed to be it it was supposed to
be like maybe seven or eight comics or
something like that it wasn't really
supposed to be that far that long at all
instead ended up being like this big 34
issue thing where it told us to fall out
and eventually I just got rid of it all
with Secret Invasion but nonetheless you
know it was basically one of these
things we were just kind of like swept
under the rug like once it was all said
and done and the superhuman Registration
Act was gone away all the Avengers and
the superheroes were like well I mean
you know yeah
we fought but we're BFFs now so it's
okay that's basically how it played out
so it's it's really it's really weird um
the freedom shield let's see um can we
ever get taskmaster explained i was
reading a solo series from 2012 and it
contradicts everything else ever shown
about his character so i'm a bit
confused as to what is what okay um I
don't know if I'll ever do taskmaster
unless it becomes relevant during secret
war see the reason we're doing Age of
Apocalypse the reason we're doing planet
hulk what we're doing future imperfect
stuff like that is because a lot of
those things are relevant to what's
going on bidding a lot of those things
are relevant to what's going on with
secret wars if we jump in and in a
secret wars they say okay here's
apocalypse any rules the territory
called the age of apocalypse and it's
that universe continued on you guys are
going to be like Rob what's going on how
did this universe come into existence in
the first place that's what we're doing
Age of Apocalypse plus it's one of the
greatest stories ever told in the
history of Marvel Comics it's awesome in
scale so we're definitely going to do
that but you know taskmasters not really
relevant there but here's the deal
whenever a whenever a new story comes
out when everything's jump in and
explain Singapore when everything's jump
in and a new writer comes out and they
say okay guys here's the story and
they're giving you the origins of
taskmaster or they're telling you here's
how taskmaster works that's the new
standard basically think of it as like a
reboot within a reboot it's a reboot but
it's not really a reboot it was the same
thing with like daredevil yellow for
example like we had we had a frank
miller's one of daredevil which made you
know Rupert not Rupert Murdoch Matt
Murdock's father a really really brutal
and mean person jeph loeb came back in
daredevil yellow and said nope that's
not the case his father was a kind guys
father was a nice guy and that's a
standard going forward so just think
about it that way that's really you know
how those how those things work so
whatever you ran in 2012 which has
master is the accurate taskmaster at the
moment that's the way things are and
they can pretty much just disregard you
know how he gained his abilities or any
of that stuff previous to that so I
haven't read it so I'm taskmaster was
never really that interesting to me that
I went out and picked up a picture of a
solo series so
um let's see what is that thing in my
hand this is a cigarette mod and it's a
beastly matta that this is a cigale 100
watt plus so this is a doomsday device
in case things pop off in the chat too
much I can hit this button and
everybody's computers all of you who are
watching the last you might now your
computers are going to blow up so Jim
Carrey is carnage would be pretty
awesome like so you look at it like
Benny shows up any hijacks my my chat he
hijacks the whole live stream well you
know that's gonna be the case the
meeting he just do his live stream and
I'll just go home or I guess I already
am home I'll just sign off all right
let's scroll up here um I think there
was a question in here somewhere can I
ever explain the monitors I can try um
my knowledge about DC is nowhere near as
great as my knowledge on Marvel I mean
it was like I actually hit up cell I was
like okay sound like the cosmic entities
as they exist in DC or they organized
like the iron Marvel he's like nope
they're just kind of there and it's like
will crap so it's difficult to keep up
with but um let's see which movie do I
think we'll do better Fantastic Four or
an man in truth I think they'll do about
the same um a bit you don't have to go I
think I think they'll be about the same
I think that um that I'm the betty block
maybe you don't have to leave that is
fun um no I think that I think they'll
do about the same and the reason why is
because people are hyped people are like
yay ant-man but they're like Captain
America Civil War like it was the most
the most it was a film people were most
excited for after Avengers 2 age of
Ultron it was like the most hyped film
after Avengers 2 and so ant-man and
truth just kind of came out at a bad
time like ant-man probably it would have
been better if Aunt May had come out
after Captain America Civil War because
you know it's I mean you've got you've
got a huge blockbuster film and then
you've got the next huge blockbuster
film and then you've got this film in
between and not enough people know who
Scott Lang is I mean in truth I would
have picked Hank Pym
because Hank Pym is a more established
character and a more well-known
character bud Scott lanes more modern
and so it makes sense that they would
pick Scott Lang for the ant-man film but
nonetheless you know if I went out and
did a survey and I said okay guys like
who is an man I imagine a lot of people
are gonna say one mean like I've heard
of the name like he's an Avenger isn't
he or something like that but they're
not going to know much about him in fact
they may never refer them at all and so
you know it's it's one of those weird
things with regard to the Fantastic Four
the Fox has a track record of making
terrible Marvel based movies and so I
think a lot of people are going to go
into the Fantastic Four expecting the
worst and then being surprised if they
don't get that so I mean it's going to
be big it's a reboot of a movie so
people are going to go see a regardless
and people are going to go see ant-man
because it's a Marvel Cinematic Universe
film and I imagine that ant-man they're
going to basically draw people into
seeing and man by incorporating a lot of
important things into into that movie so
you know again it is it's it really
depends it really is going to be it's
gonna be interesting um let's see i'm
reading some Captain Marvel oh Jesus
fell yeah they bring up bringing in the
Shiar can you talk about them or do a
video like you did the Kree well the
Shiar are pretty straightforward I mean
the Shiar on too difficult to understand
their an empire that's existed for for
you know millennia for thousands of
thousands of thousands of thousands a
years they existed for a long time in
Marvel Comics I mean you had like yes I
mean they were they were big in the 90s
that was like the age of the Shiar were
the 1990s I mean you had to Cain you had
a laundry yet the Shiar Chris or the
m'kraan crystal you had gladiator you
had the Imperial Guard you had the
Phoenix force you know and all the x-men
vs. the the Imperial Guard and the trial
of Jean Grey I mean you had all these
really really cool things that went on
in the 1990s after that they just really
kind of took a backseat we knew they
were there and they would show up in
conflicts but they weren't nearly as
prominent as they used to be a model try
to bring them back they tried to make
him prominent again when they gave us
the oh god was it called war of kings
when they when they basically gave us
like Vulcan and they said okay here's
Vulcan and he's a third summers brother
and now he rules the Shiar and he's
going to war against Black Bolt and the
Kree Empire so
don't you know it's it's it's one of
those interesting things you know it's
the Shiar really relevant they're just
kind of there you know and and they're
not as important as I used to be they
actually tried to make them important
during secret wars ordering time runs
out like towards the end um gladiator
who's ruling the Shiar Empire it was
like oh my god earth is the reason why
the encourages are happening let's just
destroy the planet Earth let's just blow
it up and in the guardians of the galaxy
show up and they're like hey Avengers
like the sea are coming and they're
going to blow up your planet so you
might want to get ready for that and
then it gets kind of silly after that
but no it's it's one of those one of
those interesting things um do I think
daredevil will be in Civil War I hope so
but here's here's my concern about Civil
War here's here's my my worry about it
my worry about the about civil war is
that we're going to get too many
characters hammered in there that's why
I think civil war was just too big to do
with one movie I mean Civil War I think
should have been all of phase four but
I'm not the decision maker I'm as a fan
that has an opinion I think that with
age of Ultron we saw what happens when
you have a plot that moves too fast and
you have too many characters in it you
know we saw the same thing you know with
with spider-man 3 of course age of
Ultron was a whole nother level it was a
much better film but the fact remains
that you know we see what happens when
you have too many characters crammed
into a story and the story moving too
fast with with you know captain america
civil war you know i think there's gonna
be a lot happening in a very short
amount of time but i could be wrong it
could be very well written it could be
very organized and it could be the best
Marvel film to date I don't know it's
going to be really hard to tell I mean
of course I'm gonna go see it why the
hell would not you know the only way I
wouldn't go see Captain America Civil
War is if like the world exploded like
if the world came to an end then i
wouldn't go see it but you know if there
was a zombie apocalypse i would like go
to the movie theater barricade myself
inside and then find the movie and watch
it like that's what i would do and then
i watch it all the other movies in the
theater too and then try to find a way
to escape a zombie apocalypse like
that would be an awesome movie like
wouldn't ever be a cool movie there's
like a zombie apocalypse and somebody
just like runs into a movie theater and
just watches movies like that that'd be
pretty amazing um opinions on spider-man
casting I knew this was going to come up
as a better field is a great choice he
was solid an indras game enters game was
not well written and it wasn't nearly as
good as the Orson Scott Card book scott
card but was so good but nonetheless he
was convincing I mean he I liked him I
liked his character um it'll be
interesting seeing somebody as young as
he is jumping in and being spider-man in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but he's
also the right age to but here's the see
here's the kicker though here's the
question you have to ask are they should
you read Marvel Zombies certainly
everybody should read Marvel Zombies um
they have a lot of older characters like
a lot of these a lot of the characters
as they exist in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now look like their characters
that are their modern versions of
themselves their modern versions of
those characters throwing in spider-man
as being like you know 15 16 years old
makes sense and a lot of older
spider-man fans will probably love it
they'll say yes we get the old-school
spider-man we get to watch him grow
that's gonna be so cool but you know I
would have expected they would have
picked spider man who was a little bit
older you know the question is you know
it would have been a major continuity
thing and they said well if this guy was
spider powers exist at all this time and
he's been in New York why wasn't he part
of the Avengers and so that's why
they're going with him you know with his
his story where he just basically you
know if spider-man I don't think they're
gonna do the origin but I think they're
gonna say hey he spider-man now so we'll
see what's up what I'm thinking they're
gonna do is they're going to start the
movie like they did the Incredible Hulk
we're in the incredible hulk in the
opening sequences and the opening
credits we got the whole origin story of
The Incredible Hulk I think they're
going to do that with with Peter Parker
with the spider-man film and it makes
sense I mean everybody knows the origin
story you don't need an hour of the film
dedicated to it just give it to us and
like a five-minute opening sequence and
everybody's gonna be like okay cool
spider-man let's go um okay let's see
we'll all try and return and another MCU
movie well as far as we know he's dead
or at least were led to believe he's
dead some people are saying that he's
not that the vision didn't kill him but
the vision destroyed what was left of
Ultron so I would say that that the
ultra ultra will probably return at some
point along the line in in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in some form or
fashion but I don't think it'll be the
old Tron we know that is to say it won't
be i mean it could just be like his
consciousness got blasted out into space
that loki used the mine gym and said
okay i'm going to strip your
consciousness away from you i'm going to
incorporate it into myself for something
like that i don't know exactly how all
that worked because Ultron you know in
terms of his his development originated
with the mind Jim and so it makes sense
he would return to the mine Jim once it
was all said and done but you know I
don't know um will silk be in secret
wars ah honestly if she is she'll
probably part of it be part of spider
verse but I'm don't really care I don't
say that to be a jerk I just say that
because I never really liked so I mean
silk felt like she was just kind of
slammed in there as a character she was
just kind of crammed in there is it
alright hey guys new spider character
like spider girl but not really
spider-girl but kind of yes but not
really but you know hint hint nudge
nudge you know that's kind of how I felt
with her character I never really liked
to soak that much um let's see civil war
should be like a five hour movie of
Marvel awesomeness now I don't think
should be five hours nobody would subdue
a five hour movie but it should be like
two or three movies it should be
stretched over like it should be well it
wouldn't be the form of you but it
should be the captain america movie it
should be the maybe you're well I guess
we're not gonna get incredible hulk film
yeah it should just be stressed over a
series of movies just titled Civil War I
don't know just like three Captain
America movies and phase for her phase
three let's see the century in battle
world history is dead and centuries been
dead for quite some time they killed him
off they tried to bring him back as one
of the Horsemen of apocalypse but it
wasn't very well-received fans were like
just let him die plz just stahp
resurrecting him just let him stay dead
like I said this century the best story
he ever had was his you know Paul
Jenkins jlee story and then he just
just tanked after that Marvel just kind
of destroyed his character because he
was like Superman what can you do with
Superman you can't tell a convincing
story with Superman I mean the guys got
godlike powers how interesting could he
really be um what's my predictions with
the next issues of Secret Wars well I
mean God like I am i'm loving secret war
so far i figure there be a lot of
questions about secret wars i am i'm
really excited about secret war so far
like i love every bit of it um i'm
hoping that with issue number 3 we get a
little more here i feel like with issue
number two it was like okay guys here's
the run over of stuff and with some of
the tie-ins it's just kind of like okay
here's a force but you know while
italians are going to be self-contained
basically mean that as far as I
understand the tie-ins aren't going to
fold into the main secret war storyline
which is kind of a shame kind of
disappointing um if something that is
true I could be wrong here but it's
something that that's true you know I
imagine we'll get explanations on each
of those things but I want to see I want
to see the big picture what I think is
going to happen because this is jonathan
hickman with jonathan hickman we're
going to get more of what we got an
issue number two and we're going to get
more of what we got with this you number
two initial number 4 and so on and so
forth it probably won't be towards like
it'll probably be the last issue when we
learn how everything happened we learned
what happened to molecule man we learned
what happened that led to the creation
of battle world we learn what happened
between the conflict between dr. doom
and the beyonders we learn all that
stuff you know and so I mean it's
hickman you know thank God it's only
eight issues because Hickman can drag
stuff out I mean those are you guys are
read Hickman stuff you guys know Hickman
can write a long story and I'm glad we
don't have to wait three years for the
story dan but um I don't know I mean
it's here's a question I would post to
you guys once Secret Wars is done once
we're into just like a battle world do
you guys think that Marvel will be able
to keep the greatness of secret wars
going because I think we can all agree
that secret wars is going to be great i
mean with hickman writing it you know
from issue number one all the way up to
issue number eight is going to be an
awesome story
can Marvel keep it going because
Hickman's leaving after secret Wars you
know he's going to DC and so I'm curious
to see can they keep it great I don't
know um where is Odin we don't know um
the the Thor that we saw in Thor's I
mean those are all just Thor's and so
that's not Odin from the earth-616
continuity or like the main Odin you
know from the Marvel Universe no clue
where he's at um maybe we'll get a
reveal maybe we won't I mean that's
that's the question that's kind of the
problem with with somebody like Secret
Wars is you know I can't answer the
questions until we get them and we
haven't gotten them yet I mean it may be
that will see you know the female
version of Thor and you know in the only
all different Avengers and she'll tell
us what's going on you know she'll tell
us were the old for wind where you know
figure and all those characters are she
may tell us she may not you know we
don't really know um do I like the Joe
fix it whole yes I was so excited to see
Joe fix it come back I was like oh yes I
mean he shows up like it's for those of
you guys who don't know that's the Joe
fix it Hulk that we saw at the end of
Planet Hulk that met Steve Rogers it has
like that great big hand on his chest
all that kind of stuff he was such an
awesome hope he was like your common
everyday handyman Hulk like he was cool
he was like he was the guy that you see
doing patchwork in an apartment building
Hulk like that's the Hulk that we all
know and love who would I recruit as an
Avenger that hasn't been a member let's
see between ghost rider Electra black
cat constrictor etc um I choose a
lecture i lecture is probably the most
formidable assassin on the planet like
she is amazing in the blog me I guess
she's dead now that before the death of
every all the all the non-essential
basically characters from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe um I think that she
was probably the best assassin and she
would have been amazing as part of the
Avengers the problem is that like she
was a bad guy and she was always trying
to kill daredevil and that's kind of a
problem if you're in a Venator here's my
question if you guys could add some body
to the roster of the Avengers who isn't
an Avenger okay know if you guys could
add a
villain to the roster of the Avengers
which villain would you pick that's my
question that'd be a cool question um do
I know who she Thor is yes we already
talked about that is Jane Foster I have
a video about that actually is there
going to be more deadpool comics my god
man there's this okay that mono manke
it's like the kid when someone's like
this anybody have any questions he's
just like jumping up and down in the
back of the classroom and it's like oh
my god really um there's Deadpool secret
secret wars Deadpool secret secret wars
is basically dead pool in the original
Secret Wars event it's a three-part
series of final part comes out at the
end of july i think um but i don't know
if we're gonna get any more deadpool
comics after that I have no idea I don't
know MSC that's the funny thing Marvel
says deadpool's dead the earth-616
version a Deadpool is dead Marvel says
Wolverine stead the earth-616 version of
Wolverines dead we know that with
reading secret wars with reading a
secret wars battle world that Wolverines
still alive it's just a different
version of Wolverine from a different
reality we know that Wolverine will be
part of x-men 92 so you know it'll be
interesting um Dwayne Johnson you'd pick
Dwayne Johnson to be on the Avengers
Punisher netflix series or a movie
definitely a Punisher movie but i will
say that somebody asked earlier about
dirty laundry dirty laundry is probably
like that movie was ten minutes like
nine or ten minutes that was better than
any of the other punisher stuff that
we've seen in any film or anything like
that was better than all that stuff that
was the Frank hassle we all know and
love like it's funny because for those
of you guys who aren't familiar with
Frank hassle if you saw the first day or
the first Punisher movie the scene where
he's using the popsicle and he's
torturing that guy if that were in the
comics like he really would have used
that blowtorch and he really would have
just totally flayed that guy's back like
he really would have just burned him to
death like no questions asked you know
he would have been like sorry about your
luck I need information that you have
and I'm gonna get it um good afternoon
Paul Jones
but yeah it was definitely it was
definitely pretty solid Punisher will
come in daredevil iron fist I mean if
we're going to see Punisher and the
marvel cinematic universe will see them
at Netflix before we see him in a film
and the reason why is because it's a
safer bet it makes more sense it's
cheaper to put the Punisher and like two
or three episodes of Netflix and the
daredevil or in the Iron Fist series and
it is to make a two and a half hour film
about his character he's just not you
know if people aren't willing to take
the risk people aren't willing to say
I'm going to go and spend you know nine
or ten dollars on a Punisher film coming
off of the punisher film with thomas
jane and then punisher war zone even
though it's a Marvel Cinematic Universe
film you'll get more than you normally
would but they won't get enough to
offset the cost because I mean there
have to be a lot of destruction you're
talking about a lot of blowing stuff up
you're talking about a lot of people
dying you're talking about you know all
kinds of different things though it has
to go on in that film and so you know
it'd be kind of difficult to do let's
see why was the 616 the main Marvel
Universe that was just a random
numerical designation way back in the
1980s when Alan Moore wrote I guess he
was part of Marvel UK he wrote a story
called The Crooked world about Madame
Josh furs and in Captain Britain and
Captain Britain learns that he's
actually part of a multiversal group
called the captain britain core and when
he's there in this sort of nexus of the
multiverse they basically like designate
the main mobile universe as earth-616
and it just stuck after that it just
that's that's really it like it just
kind of stayed that way so I mean there
there really wasn't you know there
really wasn't a there really wasn't like
a basis behind it it's just kind of how
it was um I don't think you don't think
Punisher could appear in some war I mean
he could you know but it I mean there's
there's a lot of ways to wow there's a
lot of ways to to pull that off there's
a lot of ways to bring the punisher into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and you
could do it you could have them feature
in civil war but the question is why is
it here you know like why not you know
do something else why not you know put
them in netflix or something like that
there would be too many questions that
the answer or ask the people they
wouldn't be able to answer so you know I
mean they'd have to do with like a basis
for him they would have to bring him and
they'd have to say Oh Dolph Lundgren
yeah the original Punisher you know they
would have to like bringing me they'd
have to do something you know to to make
him relevant so convergence or Secret
Wars hmm i would say convergence is good
convergence is interesting if you like
the older stories because i don't care
about the main story you know the older
stories are what are relatively
interesting but i haven't really been
interested in the old stories recently i
would say secret wars to me is more
interesting because i'm more interested
in Marvel than i am in DC plus Marvel
has never done this before and so this
is all new territory DC's done stuff
like this before I mean they've you know
it's they've they've rebooted their
continuity they've changed things up
they've done all that stuff before it's
not new you know with Marvel this is new
so um that was obviously a cosmic kitty
pryde at the end is that what you're
talking are you talking about a force
because I couldn't all I saw was cosmic
kitty pryde um we're not sure I mean we
I mean honestly we won't know until they
tell us but I would wager and say you're
probably right so okay here's a question
I have for you guys because coming out
on Tuesday for top 5 Tuesday is the top
five Deadpool moments the Tuesday after
that is going to be the top five
lanterns so I already know who my
favorite lantern is who then will in my
opinion who that number one Green
Lantern is who is the number one green
lantern for all you guys like who is the
best or not okay let's not say the best
green lantern who's the best lantern I
mean the best like anybody who's ever
wielded a green lantern or a white
lantern or red lantern or any of those
who is the best Lantern wheeler in DC
Comics that's what I want to know what's
going on digital wave welcome um let's
see Chris Pine would be perfect for how
hernia would be pretty good
sky and Avengers or in humans movie um
the sky will be developed more I think
and eight as a shield before will
actually see her in in any of the
Avengers film although we might see her
and the sea I knew like right off the
bat kyle rayner if both slept I'll
brainer um I would say right off of the
you know with with sky Daisy Johnson
will see her develop more I think she's
going to be our segue into the Inhumans
I see her playing a bigger role in phase
four you know I mean well maybe and
maybe later on a phase three you know
again I mean we get our Inhumans movie
between the which mean infinity infinity
War part 1 and infinity War part 2 and
so I see her kind of phasing in and
introducing a city in humans which means
she'll get a bigger role but I don't see
her in captain america civil war she
might be though but if she was if we
would have known by now I mean with all
the information that's coming out all
the pictures all that kind of good stuff
i mean all that i find it very difficult
to believe that Moffat will be able to
keep it hush-hush that she's going to be
in civil war and nobody found out about
it I mean I don't think that's gonna
happen so how do i think that Thanos was
going to take the visions mine stone and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe simple
you're just going to walk up behind him
smack them in the back of the head and
catch the gym as it falls out I think
he's probably going to destroy the
vision um here's what I think is going
to happen I think infinity War part one
is going to be fano scaning like the
last of the infinity gems I think that
as the Marvel Cinematic Universe
progresses towards the infinity war
we're going to see the fan O's capturing
gems like I think in one in in like you
know one of the movies we'll see like
maybe the end of Captain America Civil
War something like that will see that
like Thanos is walking into these
Andorian fortress after like
obliterating everybody and then just
like taking the stones or taking the
power gym you know I think that will
that's that's the kind of thing that
we'll see and then I think an infinity
war will see him getting the last of the
gems and then an infinity War part 2
that's when he's going to start
unleashing holy hell and start waging
war against everybody and we're going to
see the whole Infinity Gauntlet story
unfold
um what's the film you are most hyped
about for Phase three oh man that's a
good one um I mean I want to say
infinity war but everybody's hyped about
infinity war so aside from that one
because that's kind of a given i mean so
there's there's no one out there who's
like man I route like I don't care about
infinity war like nobody nobody out
there thinks that and if they do there's
something wrong with them if you're not
excited for infinity war there's
something wrong with you is what I say
um let's see I'd see the Inhumans you
know I'm really psyched for the Inhumans
I think it's about timing in humans got
some love um I think that'll be the big
the movie i'm looking forward to the
most in phase 3 but there's also Captain
Marvel I mean there's black panther
there's dr. strange I'm looking forward
to all of them there we go i'm looking
forward to every movie in phase 3 like
guard is the galaxy two yeah that comes
out in phase 3 guy there's so much
because there's so much great students
great stuff coming out what's going on
elias elyas i guess it is let's see can
I see sky-quake doing a secret warriors
kind of spin-off show on agents of
shield I don't think there'd be enough
interest for them to do a spin-off show
I mean in truth right now the popularity
of Ages so she was hanging on as it is I
mean people are I guess hanging on us on
the best phrase I could say that people
look at the show and they say okay I'm
watching this because of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because maybe we'll
see Coulson tie back in again or
something like that like you know that's
not something that I'm really sure about
what I will say though is that again
secret warriors I don't think there's
gonna be a whole lot of interest I don't
think there's enough interest in the
character of sky herself to hold her own
show she's a great character you know
she's a really really cool really cool
concept in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but I see her coming in and actually
being a character that will kind of
evolve in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
on her own and then maybe or maybe not
actually you know get a major role I
don't know it's it's weird I mean I
think she'll be a minor character to be
honest
no one watches the agents of shield no
one except like a few million people
that watch it every week I mean no one
besides them like you're right um do I
think there will be any face for in the
Marvel Universe oh definitely I mean
there's nothing to be a face where why
wouldn't there be I mean they're they're
quaking they're making way too much
money off of this to not do a face for
like no that'd be crazy talk um let's
see Rob Suicide Squad Joker reaction I
hmm man I I'm on the fence about the
Joker I'm not sure I know a lot of
people are just like yes we get Joker
even those jared leto whatever who cares
it's the Joker the Joker looks like a
character from oz um I'm not sure how I
feel here's the question I think we have
to ask are we going to get a dark
sadistic Joker that's not funny or are
we going to get in over the top humorous
Joker that is funny that's my question
um I don't know I like the over-the-top
like the humorous but still sadistic
Joker like I like that fine line joke
with that you know right right there
where you know that he's crazy enough to
just kill people for no real reason but
you also know that while it doesn't seem
like he has a reason that he actually
does and he has a plan and it's all
going towards something ridiculous like
copywriting fish that he's made to look
like himself I mean you know I don't
know I think it'll be I don't know i'll
really just kind of have to wait to be
honest to see how it plays out do I
think that the MCU is rushing Thanos no
no i don't i think there's enough
knowledge and enough interest out there
about Thanos that your average moviegoer
is going to say i know who that guy is I
know what's up with that guy as soon as
they announced it I mean videos where
everywhere like you guys remember when
the Avengers film ended and they
revealed phantoms like there were videos
everywhere everybody
talking about Thanos Thanos this Thanos
that who is Stannis panels explained I
mean I jumped on that high train the
video has like 200,000 views you know
it's it's you know everybody was talking
about Thanos there's enough hype out
there now and enough people know who he
is that they know that this is leading
towards the Infinity Gauntlet and so in
truth if you want to see what happens
just read Infinity Gauntlet I think
they're pacing Thanos pretty well I
think they're they're keeping him at the
same speed they need to in order to
maintain interest but to also remind
people that yes Thanos out there and
he's capturing the Infinity stones I
mean I think they're building it up well
because remember we have like like five
or six films before the infinity war
happens so it's not like infinity war
happens tomorrow I mean we've got
several films coming up before that
takes place so um let's see do I think
after 33 Ragnarok that Natalie Portman
let's scroll back up Natalie Portman
would take the mantle of Thor and Hammer
like in the comics man let me tell you
something that is that would be a gamble
if hey let's say that for three Ragnarok
plays out the same way does in the
comics when let's say Thor dies man if
Natalie Portman is like the world needs
a Thor and like she picks up the hammer
here's what's gonna happen there's going
to be initial like freaking out people
are gonna be like oh my god Natalie
Portman far they're gonna be like yeah
or like we get free mail for Natalie
Portman's gonna be really the hammer
like girls everywhere gonna be like yes
we get a female version of four and then
it's going to wear off and the question
is going to be okay now can she live up
to the hype can she be a four can they
write her well can they give her good
action sequences that Natalie Portman
can physically play out or that they can
have a convincing stunt double play out
in her stead that'll be the question um
you know that that I think will be the
the big issue with her character I think
she could pull it off Natalie Portman is
an incredible actress like she's
unbelievable so you know obviously she
could play off the character
convincingly the question is can they
write her convincingly and that I think
would be the big deal I would say that
if they did they probably could
we could write a good female version of
Thor I think that what we're gonna I
think I think with the direction the
marvel cinematic universe is going in
the direction of the comics are going in
we're going to see a Jane Foster Thor
there's a reason why it was revealed to
us that Jane Foster was Thor instead of
like Valkyrie or enchantress or any
number you know seff I would have picked
SEF to be to wield the hammer of Thor
before I picked you know Jane Foster to
be truthful with you guys you know if I
were going to tell the truth here I
would have picked her I would have said
it makes more sensitive would be Jane
for abby's if instead of Jane Foster but
nonetheless you know there's a reason
why things have been done the way we
haven't really seen this yet um if Thor
is holding his hammer can somebody pick
up for we haven't seen that in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe yet that's my
question could model make another
spin-off show let me tell you so much
more what makes it spin I'll show about
anything I'll watch it the question is
what would the spin-off show be i mean i
think that with with luke cage jessica
jones iron fist and daredevil the next
expected person for them to make a show
on would be like the punisher that's why
i say it makes sense that they will say
we're going to go ahead and throw out
you know the punisher of hearing and a
couple instances in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe netflix series and then just
straight up like give us a Punisher film
that were I'm sorry I'm Punisher netflix
series that would make sense test the
waters you know irrelevant titles in
secret wars honestly it's difficult to
tell right now because the way they're
doing Secret Wars we're doing secret
wars in three phases the first phase is
last days here's here's the way it works
guys Secret Wars is one of those things
where Secret Wars isn't over till it's
over my last days is basically like
here's a Marvel killing off and ending
all the titles that are currently
ongoing so black widows ongoing story is
going to end with with last days and all
that kind of gets tough a black widows
last days goes all the way until the end
of the end of suger Wars the Silver
Surfer solo series all those all those
things and so it won't be until Secret
Wars ends and we're officially into
whatever the new world is or whatever
things are going to be after Secret Wars
is over
that we can say whether or not it's
actually over and so again last days
wraps everything up battle world gives
us the foundation for everything as it
exists now or I guess war zones gives us
a foundation for everything as it exists
now all the things going in a conflict
and all that kind of good stuff and then
battle world is what everything is going
to be when this is all over its that's
why it's really difficult to tell that's
why we're doing all these stories that's
why you know yes secret wars number
three is going to come out but before we
do Secret Wars number three we're going
to go over future imperfect we're going
to do old man Logan we're going to do
all these stories because we don't know
if Marvel is going to do like ending
with planet hulk I thought Planet Hulk
was going to be a retelling of the
planet hulk story nope they're just
saying it's a great big huge territory
and it houses all these versions of The
Incredible Hulk so now people who read
the original Planet hope or people who
are looking up planet hulk want to know
the differences between the two you know
with the Age of Apocalypse are they
going to retell the Age of Apocalypse
story we don't know so we're going to do
age of apocalypse future imperfect we
know that the leader of all the hoax on
this in this green land territory and
Planet Hulk on battle world is the
maestro but unless we go for future
imperfect you guys are going to know who
maestro is and you're not going to know
the significance of the maestro how much
more powerful is the maestro from your
ordinary Incredible Hulk that we see in
the earth-616 continuity that's the kind
of thing we're going to have to go over
and the kind of thing they were going to
have to do so it'll be interesting um
let's see movies of phase 4i think phase
4 is going to be a sequel to a lot of
different things but I think we're also
going to see I don't know it's hard to
tell I mean to see the problem with
infinity war is we don't know where it's
going to leave off it'd be so much
easier if we knew it was going to lead
off if we knew that was just going to
end with the defeat of Thanos the
destruction of everything and the
recreation of the universe because of
that happened then they could just
basically reboot everything but if it's
not going to happen you know I don't
know it's weird okay do you guys want me
to pitch okay you guys want me to pitch
like my face for you guys want me to
give you guys my idea for phase 4
because I will if you want me to yeah
let's see do you think the universal
studios will allow universal studios
will allow oh do I think daredevil or
any of the other netflix series will
cross over with ages of she'll
definitely I think we'll see all that
stuff crossover at some point along line
you don't make sense to it'll be cool um
let's see do you want a movie about
Deadpool killing the Marvel Universe yes
I would so go see a movie about Deadpool
kills the marvel universe that would be
somebody said not really know I don't
really want to hear your idea Rob give
your ideas to yourself um the arrow
season finale instead okay before we get
into this face for thing we need to talk
about the flash season finale the flash
season finale seemed very confusing to a
lot of different people okay here's what
we said with the flash season finale
when the flash show first started we had
two points in time alright we had the
death of Nora Allen when she was killed
presumably by the reverse-flash and the
flash from the future that's the second
point in time the second point in time
is the time in which evar Thawne
traveled into the past and attacked nor
Allen now here was a question the
question was okay if he's from the 21st
century how is it that Barry Allen
travels into the past or travels I'm
sorry how was a very Allen is in the
same time as a abarth on how is he alive
then we don't really know that so I
think the way things are playing out is
this one we had this linear timeline we
had this time that no it's it's not out
here oh the flash isn't out there yet ok
well the flash isn't out there yet then
we won't talk about it yet I don't want
to spoil it for people I'll make a
separate video so we can talk about it
okay so phase for phase 4 predictions
all right um hmm god this is gonna be a
tough one okay so let's say that that
phase 3 that infinity war ends with
Thanos wiping out everything and then
let's say that the captain america or
adam war
or some character doesn't matter who it
is grabs the Infinity Gauntlet and says
we're going to reset everything back to
the way it was before all this started
and so band they reset everything
alright if if they reset everything it's
a blank slate which means that we get to
basically do everything over again the
success of phase 4 is contingent on a
lot of different things one of the most
important things is can Marvel get the
rights back to the x-men and the
Fantastic Four or can they strike a deal
with Fox to feature the x-men and the
Fantastic Four and their Marvel
Cinematic Universe if they can that's a
whole nother phase right there I mean
you've got x-force X Factor you got
Generation X you've got factor 3 you've
got mr. sinister you've got the
Sentinels I mean you've got all kinds of
stuff you can even do the age of
apocalypse in its entirety if you wanted
to you know that's that's entirely
possible assuming that doesn't happen
and assuming that the end of infinity
ward is not result in the reboot of
everything i would say that what we'll
probably see is the house of m in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that's what I
would want to see you know i would say
starting with phase for that the vision
is scott at which somewhere along the
line produce a child or produce a couple
children the result is that the children
aren't real and the squalor which can't
handle it maybe should get swept up in
her own illusions or something like that
but whatever the reason is the result is
that she loses her mind and so face face
forward partly i got the burbs face for
is the Scarlet Witch trying to deal with
losing everything trying to deal with
her inability to cope with that reality
and altering reality instead I don't
know at this point it's really hard as
hell if we don't get that if we don't
get that then we'll just see a change
and a whole bunch of different things am
able to see sequels to all kinds of
stuff will see a new Miss model film
we'll see I guess captain marvel film
we'll see maybe Kamala Khan folded in as
miss marvel as part of the Inhumans
we'll see a lot of the current stuff or
a lot of the newer stuff going on we may
even see a reboot where we basically see
like the Secret Wars carrying over into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is really
difficult to know with marble not having
the rights to the x-men or the Fantastic
Four they're limited
in terms of their most popular
characters I mean it's really difficult
to do you know phase one if they were
going to introduce some of the minor
characters and make the major characters
that would have been the time to do it
but now they really can't I mean I guess
you couldn't face for but it'd be really
tough to do but again we get more
according to the galaxy I mean it's
going to be it's gonna be weird let's
see is there any way Deadpool can kill
Thanos I mean if Deadpool gets the
Infinity Gauntlet but Deadpool by
himself with no special weapons not at
all not a chance phase 4 has came the
Conqueror when was that confirmed the
Inhumans are taking the main stage and
pays for yeah I mean it makes sense they
can't get the right to the x-men back of
course they would elevate the Inhumans
that's what I would do um let's see what
am I think about an alpha flight movie I
would not go see a movie about alpha
flight will there ever be a Marvel DC
crossover I want there to be one like I
really want there to be a crossover film
with Marvel and DC I think it'd be
awesome I think it'd be hilarious to see
um I think it's gonna happen but I think
it'd be awesome to see let's see who
died think would win in a fight Superman
with all the lantern gyms or Thanos with
the Infinity Gauntlet oh my god Superman
with all the lantern all the the lantern
rings or Thanos with the Infinity
Gauntlet I'd say theta for the Infinity
Gauntlet I mean the Rings don't have the
power to warp reality may just would
allow Superman and create all kinds of
constructs but you know it's well it
would have to be in earth-616 because as
was established in the the marvel vs DC
crossover actually i think it was jla
versus Avengers or jla and Avengers
whenever the Infinity Gauntlet does not
work outside of its native universe and
so like dark side tried to pick it up
and try to use it and he was like well
this sucks so he just like threw it on
the ground that was it
um and yeah if it was in the earth-616
universe with the Infinity Gauntlet
would work sweet man wouldn't have a
chance I mean no not not a chance not at
all let's see I think we will ever see
the beyond her the Living Tribunal and
the one above all in the MCU maybe um I
mean cosmic entities exist in a Marvel
Cinematic Universe I mean they replaced
entropy with oblivion in the Earth's are
they replace oblivion with entropy
whatever was they replace it they
basically switched them change their
names in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and so then we'll see cosmic entities I
mean well you know I'm sure we'll
actually see them in some form we know
death exists like we know we know that
she's actually there um you know I don't
we haven't seen her so far but we know
that she's actually alive because status
is obsessed with the idea of her you
know we know that we'll probably see
some very I mean there's people who have
been saying that like Stanley's the one
above all no but I think it's really
just more fanfare than anything else but
no I think we'll definitely see some see
some cosmic entities I don't know why we
wouldn't let's see do i watch
constantine i saw the pilot of
constantine didn't really get into it
really wasn't my thing i was just kind
of like it wasn't really feeling it can
you explain expedited to in secret wars
yes we will definitely do a video about
expediting too because I'm about you
guys but I am excited about x-men 92 x x
92 is going to be absolutely amazing who
would win silver surfer or the vision
silver surfer he was just fade like you
would he rearranged the the atoms of the
vision
let's see do I ever think they will make
a cable Deadpool movie maybe but I don't
think they will I mean yeah I don't know
it depends on held on how Deadpool does
Deadpool is going to be a success
because it's right at our but they
haven't done anything with cable yet and
so I don't know I don't know come here
be interesting um the flash vs world
breaker Hulk oh god that's a good one um
I don't know I mean okay God that the
ATAF when the flash is super fast
there's no way world record hope to be
able to catch the flash but world
breaker Hulk is so much stronger than
the flash so the question is would a
flash be able to do any damage even if
you can move really fast could he even
could even hurt the Incredible Hulk I
mean I would even be able to hurt him at
all I think I think honestly I think it
just comes out to be a draw I mean the
flash would be too quick for world
record hope to catch and world burger
Haut could be too strong for the flash
to hurt so I think you'd literally just
see the flash just like endlessly
punching World Recor Hulk and nothing
happening I don't know um let's see do I
play any Marvel or DC games I've played
marvel marvel heroes 2015 I think it is
I haven't played anything from DC yet
well no I've played like Arkham Asylum
and stuff like that i think i might play
arkham origins i'm not really sure but
i'm not a huge fan of those kind of
games i mean they're not really you know
I'm not really big into those I was a
kind of I'm more of like a like an RPG
like a Skyrim you know destiny kind of
fan than anything else although this
would be so boring because it's just the
same thing all the time let's see
century and the MCU I don't think we'll
see century in the MCU I mean we could I
mean it'd be a cool character to
introduce but if we do it needs to be
appalling is in jail a story that
introduces a man at least I would hope
it would be so um dark side versus
Thanos we've seen that we've seen dark
side versus panos and the
I can't refer was normal vs. DC or the
Avengers jail a crossover it was one of
those two how old am I I am 31 years old
what are your thoughts about the dock
green Hulk the the whole a second well
ask your question again there's so many
questions coming in now like it's
difficult to keep up in phase 4 do you
think any other chronology will take
place what do you mean like story arcs
I'm not really sure what you mean am i
watching Gotham know who would win flash
from the CW or Quicksilver ooh that's a
good one probably flash from the CW I
mean quick so I don't know you guys but
quicksilver's seemed kind of slow and
the Avengers 2 age of Ultron I mean I
but for a character that could run it
like mock 11 in the comics I expected
him to be faster than that I mean he was
kind of slow um a squirrel girl movie I
would go see a movie about Squirrel Girl
definitely Adam warlock vs dog okay now
it's all those these verses things is
all anybody's asking about his versus
things what do I think about a runaways
TV show or a movie in the MCU The
Runaways never really resonated with me
I know the runaways have been around for
a long time but they never really liked
caught traction with me I also really
too interested in seeing there's a scene
the scene it they really seem like a
cheap version of like the new mutants
you know or Generation X I mean they
even though Generation X wasn't really
that great but um you know that's kind
of what it seemed like to me so I never
really got to end them who are your top
three writers and artists oh god okay
top three writers and artists well I
mean number one it's definitely
claremont and john byrne because of
everything they did with the x-men back
in the 80s um the next I mean yes that's
my top you know that's this I'm going to
say that's number one I know it's like
you know put them together this unless
you're talking about writers and artists
and ranking each of them individually i
would say that number one is claremont
and
John Byrne number two is Jonathan
Hickman and anybody else and number
three is Jim Lee and any writer so
that's my that's my my 1 2 3 I was
saying coming in number four as at a
very very close for is probably Paul
Jing is in jail e so uh uh let's see do
i watch anime I used to watch dragonball
z whose cloak and dagger cloak and
dagger are the result of an experiment
cloak has the ability to create to
basically like immerse people and
teleport them and i cant rember what
dagger does let's see Rob do you would
you like to see another Hulk movie yes I
really want to see another incredible
hulk movie I don't think we'll get one I
don't think we'll see one but I would
really love to see another incredible
hope film I think it would be fun to see
this he should just just while and out a
planet hulk film would be preferable I
would love to see planet hulk and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I don't think
we will one because it would just be too
expensive to make and two because you
know Marvel's already announced they
can't make an incredible hulk film but i
would love to see planet hulk because
planet hulk would lead to a world war
hulk and i want to see a world breaker
whole pissed off and just unleashing all
kinds of havoc on the planet earth like
that so that's what i want to see so
anyway guys um I need to get to work on
age of apocalypse or get to work on
recording Age of Apocalypse so remember
to check in the description for the
channel that I suggest was of course
again I do that at the beginning of all
my videos of all my Q&A sessions I
suggest you guys check out a channel
that I have in my description a channel
that's starting out a channel that's
kind of getting into things and just a
way for you guys to be kind of decide
you know whether or not you want to want
to help that channel grow become part of
the community or else just kind of like
leave it at that but anyway um yes Age
of Apocalypse part one comes out
tomorrow the top five Deadpool moments
comes out on tuesday and then I think
we're going to try to finish out Age of
Apocalypse for the rest of the week so
anyway um yeah I'm going to go ahead and
go ahead and bounce off here and I'll
catch you guys later pretty